hey y'all what up it's your girl Liza
koshy and these are my GQ Essentials
[Music]
two I'm so excited look at that this
situation and unwrap it before your eyes
actually it might get everywhere this is
powdered peanut butter this situation
I'm about to put you on this is so good
in smoothies yogurt ice cream you can
put it into like a peanut sauce if you
take a little bit of this mix it with
water mix with soy sauce and honey it's
kind of messing salad dressing get into
it and mix this with water and mixing it
with yogurt too just like extends it
into this massive peanut butter batter I
just go in I love peanut butter so much
does anybody have a peanut allergy in
here
literally this just being in the air
will set you off you got Abby pen you
good okay that's that
panty liners this is my next essential
and it's not what you think it's for
it's not from a downstairs this is
actually for my upstairs it's for my
armpits nice so this is a hack that I
learned on set and from just being a
puddle of sweat thanks Dad passed down
that Gene hard so what you do is you
actually tape this to the inside of the
fabric of your shirt it absorbs your
sweat that way you don't stain your
shirt and like let's totally normalize
sweat stains you're putting in work
sweat baby sweat but if you're on camera
for whatever reason you'd rather not
have it there this is a great hack you
can also put it on your back and I do
I'm covered in 37 panty liners a day
it's my big boy it's my son I
love the air fryer okay I'm especially
passionate about the air fryer this is
God's hot breath baking my food I uh
call myself avatar the Last Air fryer
quiz me anything give me give me any
kind of vegetable poultry fish
cauliflower 370 15 minutes anybody else
zucchini 370 15 minutes anybody else
400.
35.
yeah I love it so freaking much it's so
easy to meal prep and his buddy yeah I
loved creating like little portions
throughout the week I basically I'm
Octomom when I meal prep I make like
eight meals for myself not for my kids
so this I doused myself in perfume did I
watch Sydney Sweeney's GQ Essentials I
did I sprayed on my ankles now thanks
Sid but this is the special perfume that
my mom actually hunted down for me I
broke mine while traveling and it
cracked open in my bag and I smelled
amazing for weeks but it was all over my
clothes and now my mom went hunting for
this specific one and I love it so
because of Sydney I sprayed on an ankle
I can't because I'm wearing really cute
boots that you can't see thanks a lot
I'm in a pan you want a pan thank you
thank you I wanted them featured so bad
I thrifted them thank you okay back up
here thank you this situation goes on
the wrist goes behind the ear neck
armpit downstairs back porch everywhere
but I love this situation I always get
compliments on it I used to be fearful
of wearing perfume because they say if
you wear perfume you're not emitting
your pheromones and you'll attract the
wrong mate super weird but uh I started
to attract the wrong men in my life so
[Music]
so these little baby shoes that look
like they should be hung up on a
Christmas tree are actually my cult
shoes they're my soul cycle shoes I did
sell my soul uh my soul and my ass
belongs to Soul cycle I Soul cycle on
the regular degular I love it so much
it's like you can jam out to EDM you
click your shoes in and you just cycle
to like a concert in the dark like two
years ago I fully passed out in a cycle
class and you just saw these shoes just
spinning on their own I had to slip them
off and I walked out into the really
white aggressively light Lobby and I got
a free apple juice and a free class so
if you want a free class just pass out
in one
next
yeah
this is a plant but it's also essential
this is RC baby I'm so proud and so my
whole voice changed right now because
this is the character that I voice in
Transformers I'm super stoked to be
voicing this Fierce Autobot it is
actually the second time that we're
going to be seeing RC in a live action
film but she has a storyline this time
and I'm so excited for you know her
existence in the universe to be honored
she is the Ducati 916 so she is a Ducati
body baby and she's like transforms let
me see I'm so honored I'm so excited to
give one of these right we're ordering
55 from my little cousins and nieces and
nephews thank you
this is my MooMoo my captain my Texan is
screaming my actually my Indian is
screaming more so my Texan is yodeling
but both sides of my culture wear large
large pieces of fabric around the house
and to bed and I love this one so much I
just got it I'm super stoked about it
it's gonna have like my face oil stands
all over it very soon so I'm glad it's
clean today for your viewing but this is
so silky So Soft so massive and I used
to wear giant t-shirts as a kid growing
up and then I graduated into a woman and
now we're in my mumus and I'm gonna slip
into this right after the shoe because
this
I have been lit on fire once with the
moo moo that it's a lot of fabric so you
just gotta make sure you're careful when
you cook the most relaxing article of
clothing that you can possibly put on
your body
[Music]
these are my gummies look this is the
one
piece of my childhood that is really
hard for me to lay to rest okay I know
I'm a full grown ass woman but it is
hard to not eat as an adult a fruit
snack pack of gummies every single night
this is what I look forward to at the
end of the day don't take this away from
me I love these guys I like don't eat
candy but yeah I do
I love a happy one I love the gummy
worms the prenatal that makes me feel
powerful as a woman yeah these two are
my favorite I love them so much the
lion's mane too I love a shroom gummy
this is my little baggie of herbs this
is actually a gift from my sister and I
was so hesitant to burn it for so long
it's a sage stick it's got these
beautiful flowers in it and I finally
burnt it maybe like a week ago and I've
had such good energy in my life since
then so I blame my sister for my health
and then this is my Palo Santo I love
the smell of it so freaking much a
huffit on The Daily I like do a whole
like a little dance right before I go to
sleep yeah I'm that girl but I like
dance around my dog a little bit I'll
dance around like my head I'll give my
head like good thoughts clear thoughts
good intentions for the next day and
then I'll knock out and go to sleep with
a crystal under my pillow I've lived in
L.A for so long now oh that's my dog's
hair
if you burn that brings good luck too
yes speaking of my family this is my
beautiful family this is actually my
sister's masked pandemic wedding so we
were all wearing masks we're all
pointing at the happy couple as my
brother-in-law and my other
brother-in-law right
I'm so freaking lucky I'm a mix
definitely a mix of my mom and dad and
yeah honored to be that yeah love my fam
I'm about to go visit them right now and
go get drunk over the course of a three
day long weekend at a family where you
you very excited for it
foreign
[Music]
this is caffeinated chocolate this is a
great boost at 3 P.M I have my coffee in
the morning and then when I start to
feel that slump this is a half a cup of
coffee get in there
you see that one bite equals half a cup
of gel and I love these guys to toss
them out everywhere I go I think that's
nice dude one hand wonder over there
what's up oh sorry
you thought it was over this is Phoebe
Waller this is my girl Phoebe
Waller bridge is an incredible actress I
love so freaking much and I named my
girl after her so Phoebe you can't go
wrong with the Phoebe's there's Phoebe
from Friends smelly cat but when she uh
got fleas the title of Phoebe Waller
Bridge's series is called fleabag she
got fleas I was so proud so upset so
proud thanks DQ those are my essentials
now I gotta get out of here I gotta fly
I got a flight to catch but I wanted you
to see my full fit
thank you